البدايه اليوم ايضا تكنولوجيا سنتحدث عن
الحرب المستعره بين شركاتها الكبرى حيث
يتحول تحديث بسيط اعتمدته ابل قبل اشهر
قبل خصوصيه المستخدمين الى زلزال لدى
شركات التواصل والتكنولوجيا ابل غيرت
اعدادات الخصوصيه التي صعدت على صانعي
التطبيقات والمعلمين تتبع سلوك المستخدمين
والان تبدا نتائج ذلك بالظهور يبدو انها
تصعيب استهداف في المستخدمين بالدعايات
تسبب بضربه لمواقع التواصل عشره مليارات
دولار هي الخسائر المتوقعه لمتى الشركه
الام للفيسبوك بسبب تراجع الاعلانات امس
تحدثنا عن تراجع الثقه من الصفات التواصل
واليوم سنتحدث عن موضوع يهم المتابعين هو
انا استهدافهم بدعيات موجهه مبنيه على
سلوكهم وتاريخ التصفح لديهم على الانترنت
سيكون من اليوم فصاعدا الصعبه الصعب لكن
يدعون ابدا اولا نبدا السنه الرهيبه
للفيسبوك او ان اسهر بلس بحسب عباره
الملكه البريطانيه الراحله
[موسيقى]
222 انها سنه الرعب والخسرات لشركه ميتا
وملكها مارك زوكربيرج الذي خسر الكثير
خلال الاشهر الماضيه ثروه ذكر بيرك مؤسس
متى ومديرها انخفضت الى 36 مليار دولار
والتي كانت تبلغ نحو 142 مليارا من عام
2021 خساره مارك زوكربيرج جاءت النتيجه
طبيعيه لاستثماره ما يزيد عن مئه وخمسين
مليار دولار امريكي في عالم المترديرس
الذي خذل مارك حتى الان بنتائجه الضباضيه
كل ذلك دفع شركه متى للقرار الصعب تسريح
نحو احد 10,000 موظف دفعه واحده لضبط
نفقات الشركه كذلك فان فيسبوك دخل في
مرحله فقدان الثقه من المستخدمين الاشهر
الاخيره لم تشهد الكثير من المنضمين الجدد
لتخسر متى اكثر من 140 مليارا من قيمتها
السوقيه
فيديو
[موسيقى]
شكرا
من هون اجى تطبيق ابل اللي عمل خاصيه منع
الاد بروفايلنج تتفضلتي في اترجتينغ توجيه
الاعلانات للمستهلكين لانه صار بدك شيء من
سمير اسمه موافقه مسبقه من المستهلك
كونسنت واضح صريح يبعث لك هل تقبلي
بالاعلان بتقولي له نعم
واحد اثنين كمان صار فيه
مسموح البروفايلن يعني تنميت المستهلك
وفقا للبحث على المحركات البحث ثالثا ما
بقى فينا نجمع البيانات شركات السوشيال
ميديا فيها تجمع البيانات من الجيول
لوكيشن من الاماكن اللي سيرتيه وتعمل لك
بروفايلينج ورابعا واخيرا امبارح اوفقا
ببريتانيا بتحكي عن تحديات اللي بتوجهها
الناس اللي بتاخذ اخبار من السوشيال ميديا
وبتقول انه في في قريبه من انه اللي
بيستهلك اخباره من السوشيال ميديا فقط
عنده نزعه اكثر الى
التطرفيش يعني
شركه جوجل
اليوتيوب مثل جيميل مثل جوجل ترانسليت ما
بتدفعي حقك مستهلك بس انا بستعمل بيانات
لاهداف تسويقيه ال- الخيار لالك يا مستهلك
بدك تدفع على كل هو للخدمات تصوري نحن عم
ندفع كل يوم او اشتراك شهري للي وصفت لك
اياهم بس عن شارك وحده اسمها جوجل اللي ما
فينا نعيش باليهم خدمات
احنا كمستخدمين كيف راح ننسفيد بطريقه غير
مباشره من هالموضوع نحن
ستعود جزئيا وتدريجيا الى ملكيتنا من حيث
القرار باستخدامه او لا بتسويقه اولاد
بالمونتايزيشن يعني ما اذا نحن نجمه ارباح
نحن وشركات الانترنت وشبكات التواصل اليوم
شركات الكبرى بالتاك هي اللي بتستفيد اكثر
شيء من البيانات المستقبل راح يكون همم
اكثر مشاركين والمستقبل لبعيد يمكن يكون
اكثر حقوق للمستهلك في استخدام البيانات
لم تستسلم بها السهوله يعني شو الطرق اللي
ممكن تعملها لتفادي هذا الزلزال الحاصل مش
مسيت استسلام هي مساله اليوم اذا بتطلع
على القطاع القطاع عنده تحديات كبيره
حكينا عن التحديات ال- القانونيه
والتنظيميه بس اليوم شفنا ناس داك هل هل
هو مثقل باسهم التاك نزلت 30% السنه واحد
اثنين عندك استثمارات هائل بالماتفرس لم
تاتي ثمارها بعد يعني فيسبوك حتى اموال
مات فيرس متى حتى اموال الطائر بعد ما
شفنا العائد على الاستثمار عندك دولار
عالي كثير قوي
التصدير لاعاده الاموال من الشركات
المتعدد الجنسيات عندك اسعار فوايد عاليه
بالسوق وعندي همم كمان همم حرب اوروبا ولا
استقرار كلها
تثمره طري التلجه للاسف اول اجراء بياخذوا
الواحد طرد الناس تدفع ثمن الموظفين وابرز
العاملين بتلك الشركات اولا
طيب في كثير ازمات حاصله بمواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي والشركات التكنولوجيا بالتحديد
من الاكثر صمودا من بينهم برايك اللي
بيبقى عنده المستهلك والمعلم ول طبعا
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه اللي بتجعلوا اقرب
الى انماط مشاهده واستهلاك الناس للاعلام
ما حدا عنده جواب يعني وين بيكون المستهلك
والمعلن والتكنولوجيا بيكون همم الخدمه
اللي راح تصمت هلا كلهم صامدين عم نحكي عن
شركات همم قطاع الاستثمار الاعلاني بقطاع
الرقم بالعالم عم نحكي عن 521 مليار دولار
اعلانات يعني شركه مثل جوجل ويوتيوب بتعمل
تقريبا 25 مليار دولار
بعدين امازون بعدين تويتر خمسه بس اذا عم
نحكي عن قطاع كثير كبير وفي استثمارات
كبيره وفيه واللي بنسميه كرييتر
مع المحتوى والمبدعين اليه تخيل العالم
اليوم بلى القطاع الكبير التكنولوجي وين
بتروح كل هالابداع وكل هالقدرات لدى لدى
الناس ودائما للحديث تتمه ولكن الوقت
ننتهى اشكرك جزيلا الشكر مستشار الاعلام
والتواصل ماذا الحياه شكرا
الف عامل في قطاع التكنولوجيا عالميا تم
او سيتم الاستغناء عن خدماتهم خلال العام
الجاري حتى منتصف نوفمبر نحو 50% من القوه
العامله لتويتر تم تصريحهم بعد ايام من
اتمام الى الماسك صفقه استحواده على منصه
التغريدات احد عشر الف موظف او نحو 13% هو
عدد الموظفين الذين تنوي مثل الاستغناء
عنهم في جميع انحاء العالم وهي اول عمليه
تسريحت جماعي في تاريخ الشركه
10,000 موظف تخطته امازون لتسريحهم بحسب
تقرير صادر عن عده صحف ومئتان موظف من
شركه نحو الف موظف هو عدده الموظفين الذين
استغنت عنهم مايكروسوفت في جميع انحاء
العالم ويقال ان السبب هو تراجع مبيعات
ويندوز لاجهزه الكمبيوتر
لتسريح 20% الموظفين معا انخفاض شحنات
الربع الثالث من اجهزه الكمبيوتر خلال
العام بنحو 15% مقارنه ب2021 ايضا 20%
كانت نسبه الموظفين الذين صرحتهم سناب شات
بعد الخسائر الكبرى بسبب تراجع الاعلانات
اما بالنسبه لنتلكس فكانت الاقل تصريحا
حيث فقد نحو 450 من موظفيها عملهم في
الفتره الماضيه